how often have you had that deja vu
moment watching a film
and how many times has that happened
while watching a disney movie
these disney flicks are filled with
allusions to pop culture
and nods to their own films from
borrowing lines to recreating images
these disney movies have sneaky
references you may not have caught on to
before
let's check them out it was an accident
guys come on
the beloved maui from moana performs a
very particular move that viewers may
recognize from the movie
journey to the mysterious island got to
do
this the peck of pop love gesture is
sported by both maui
and hank parsons that is the peck pop of
love
which makes sense since the actor for
both characters is dwayne
the rock johnson this hold up scene from
the incredibles movie is a total homage
to the film
die hard with a vengeance recognize the
similarities
now not only are these scenes presented
in the same way but the person being
held up is played by
samuel l jackson in both films looks
like
jackson doesn't have the best of luck
where's my super suit
the hercules film has some great
montages especially the training
sequence during the song one
last hope hercules phil and pegasus do
the famous crane pose on the beach
look familiar maybe that's because the
pose was originated by mr miyagi
many years prior to the karate kid
one of mushu's famous mulan moments is
not as original as it might seem
the worst nightmare the recognizable
line is actually bored from the film
rambo three your worst nightmare
the movies are obviously quite different
and have 10 years between them but the
line is made just as epic in both flicks
tangled is an action-packed film and
flynn rider often uses rapunzel's pan to
his advantage
thankfully he manages to save it just in
time
narrowly escaping the dam after it
breaks the last minute save may look
familiar as actor harrison ford
also did it in this scene from indiana
jones and the temple of doom
the main difference is that instead of a
pan the archaeologist had a hat to save
a t-rex in your rear-view mirror is not
a common occurrence
however if you're going to expect it
anywhere disney's toy story 2
is a good bet how about letting a toy
with fingers dry
then again the scene in the disney film
was actually a remake of this scene from
jurassic park
now that is a film where dinosaurs are
definitely
expected mr big in zootopia may be small
but no one can deny that he has
big personality with big vibes mr big
sir this is a simple mystery that energy
may seem familiar
since it's the same as vito corleone in
the godfather film
zootopia paid great attention to detail
in their ode to the classic as both mr
big
and corleone keep a red flower in their
lapels
king candy in wreck-it ralph uses
glasses as a way of protecting himself
hoping to escape unharmed you wouldn't
hit a guy with glasses would you
nice try but the king should have known
better since it didn't work for the
joker either when he tried the same
trick
years earlier in the 1989 batman film
you wouldn't hit a guy with glasses on
would you when woody manages to get
himself out of sunnyside in the third
toy story film
he has a close call with a sidewalk
fortunately a mysterious force protects
him at the last minute
did you notice it's the same perplexing
force that protects ethan hunt in
mission impossible
okay luther i'm going in well maybe it's
not actually so mysterious
but both woody and ethan got lucky with
those narrow escapes
explain later bruce seems unrecognizable
from the gentle
fish-loving shark we first meet when he
is feverishly trying to eat nemo and
dory
as he's getting closer to catching them
he uses a familiar line
any horror fan will know jack nicholson
originated the famous
here's johnny in the shining while the
line is an homage to the horror flick
bruce makes it his own by replacing
johnny with bruce the knight howler lab
may seem like a surprising setting for
an animated film
all right walter and jesse are back so
i'm leaving now and whitler and jesse
may be unconventional names for two
cartoon rams but
none of that was random ever consider
how similar the rams names are to
walter and jesse the leads of breaking
bat clearly the zootopia creators were
familiar with the popular tv show
from names to outfits this homage hits
all the marks
the accidentally in love montage
features fiona skillfully catching her
ring in an
epic moment impressive as it was she
wasn't the first one to pull off that
trick
three years earlier frodo managed the
same stunt
while at the prancing pony in the lord
of the rings the fellowship of the ring
it's so good to be home the toys and toy
stories sure know how to
effectively teach a lesson it takes a
creepy turn when they're trying to
educate sid
literally a very creepy head turn the
action was
even more disturbing in the exorcist
when it was a little human girl
doing the same thing we think that would
scare anyone straight
much to his surprise the frying pan
serves flynn very well in the film
tangled
and he's pretty excited about it i have
got to get me one of these
in fact he's just as excited as will
smith was after blasting off an
independence day
while the pan isn't as impressive as the
hybrid human alien fighter pilot
we can still appreciate flynn's
enthusiasm
scrat and his acorn have countless
intense moments throughout the ice age
films
but none of them so out of this world is
when they are caught in space
like many other space adventurers before
them things definitely turned out a bit
worse for the astronauts in gravity who
also found themselves floating around
dangerously in space as we've seen toy
story has
many pop culture references however
one of the most uncanny visual
similarities is the carpet in sid's
house
and the carpet in the overlook hotel in
the shining while the coloring is
different
the specific pattern is in no way a
coincidence
while many of the references disney
films make are to movies or tv shows
outside of the disney world sometimes
they deja vu themselves
for example this opening song in the
animated version of beauty and the beast
strongly resembles a scene from ichabod
and mr toad
made by disney in 1949 while the
monster's inc
intro to the scare floor is an epic
image it's not entirely unique
the same powerful group march forward
can also be found in the 1983 film
the right stuff sure the costumes
couldn't be more different but the vibe
is on point be the best monster win remy
the rat
makes a brilliant and memorable entrance
flying through a window in ratatouille
is me an epic introduction for an epic
rodent
he's not the only one that bursts onto
the screen though the 1966 film
the good the bad and the ugly introduces
the ugly
in the exact same way i run a risk
rango the chameleon has countless wild
adventures in the town of dirt and
encounters many colorful characters
hello
but did any of these characters look a
bit familiar if you're thinking of the
men in the convertible that rango lands
on the windshield of you'd be right
both the convertible and the men inside
it resemble a scene from the 1998 film
fear and loathing in las vegas
it doesn't come as much of a surprise
since johnny depp starred in both films
the disney animators are incredibly
clever and have managed to sneak in
countless references that continue to
surprise us
were you shocked that so many references
came from horror films
what are your favorite pop culture nods
found in the movies let us know in the
comments section
if you enjoyed give us a like and be
sure to hit that subscribe button to
keep up with us
at the things
you